Because you don't even take the time to bother to look at the lines.
I, I, you said, Ricky, I am not excusing you.
Well, you act like one.
You act like one a lot.
But I know finance.
I know accounting.
Well, then, well, then, why don't you understand what I'm fucking doing?
My mom does.
My mom understands completely.
You are, you are connecting.
You are connecting this.
And, uh, that's fine.
I mean, I don't, don't, don't say, I don't say, uh, I don't say it's wrong.
I don't say, do it.
What is the point?
Do it.
The point is that you're coming and telling me.
No, I am telling you.
To do things that, that I'm, I'm actually doing and that I have been doing.
And that I was the one that tried to do it.
I'm the one that tried to set up the family financials.
And then, and then you don't give a fuck.
You don't, you don't even glance.
And then you come and tell me and preach about, oh, you should do this.
You should do that.
As if I haven't been doing exactly that.
And I've been trying to get you to do it.
You are.
Like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Yes.
What the fuck?
I'm talking about.
You are full of hatred.
Full of bad.
That's what I am talking about.
Are you serious?
Yes.
Totally serious.
No.
I mean, this is completely justified.
I, I, I, I, you are.
That's what, why, why am you taking me with this?
Because I don't speak.
Because you would go say that is because I have my reason.
And the reason is because.
Because you don't, you don't look.
You don't actually take the time or care or effort to look.
That's not an excuse.
It's not an excuse.
It is literally not an excuse.
Okay.
You have your way of thinking.
It's not a mind.
It's not a, it's not a quote unquote mind way of thinking.
In Demis, me and Taiki, we literally sat for two hours.
Trying to get you to do some basic bullshit.
Fucking second grade math.
That doesn't matter.
You know why?
No matter what, I'm not going to talk to you if you continue bitching me and telling me that.
Okay?
I'm not going to.
At least, like, like, make, like, you don't even make the effort to run the spreadsheet through an AI summary.
Like, you don't even have that little bit of respect just to, like, to at least fake or, like, even lift a single finger to actually, like, look at what I'm doing.
Do it.
No, you do it.
That's your job.
It's not my job.
Yes, it is.
Okay.
That's why you're saying that it's my job.
What?
I'm telling you.
I'm not going to do this.
It's not even a job.
I'm doing an actual job.
Do it.
I am already doing it.